and we're back with your run Horton I
met Brassard fresh off their battle
gentlemen what's up that was a banger
that was a fun one
thank you was fun thank you how you
feeling post battle I feel tired it was
just was a lot a lot it was draining
just writing for him and trying to like
prepare and oh you wrote for him I mean
I didn't oh but what I'm saying is it
was just like a challenge like getting
prepared and like finding which jokes
are the best ones to like try to use
that just draining think about that
yeah what was your strategy going into
this one my strategy was definitely to
try to be clean because of my job
outside of here it's like I can't go up
and call him like you know you work for
the Oprah network yeah yeah yeah I don't
want to like jeopardize be on camera you
know saying some really like up
yeah vulgar famous judges we have a
Ken doll a Barbie doll and mr. Potato
Head
and we also have a bitch-ass nigga - we
we say bitch ass nigga on our show
that's true we say bitch and that was
the original title ya know we can say
that but I just said I'm just talking
about like you know anything that's
political - politically correct I don't
want to I feel just fine but you're
their line so I yeah they're their lines
that you they're safer to not cross but
what was your strategy going in for
Geron um I
it changed a bit I didn't want to fall
on race too much I had a learning lesson
with Frank Castillo I was like those
were just racist statements yeah I was
like let's see if I can stay away from
race I wanted to get a breath of attack
of like each joke attacks something
different and he did a great job of that
where it was like he could hit me on one
thing for one joke and a different thing
for the next show gonna different things
so it's like how how how thoroughly can
you take them down across you know
different things in just five jokes and
I think I fell back on race in the last
show this is where I lose the crowd
Geron is really into to rock climbing
because he's the only black person
gullible enough to let white people tie
ropes around him you saved it for less
the best for less but you called it you
called it out ahead of time
yeah yeah just cuz you know it's LA it's
an LA crowd they're gonna be tense about
weird stuff and I look like this so yeah
they seem to like that joke though I
think I think it did I think if I got
first with that joke it would have I
think would have been very different
right yeah but it was one though
yeah what was your favorite joke of his
he told about you man it didn't hit me
till later in the night the the Comedy
Central joke I can't cuz to me a good
roast joke is one that can't ever be
used again right it only be used on that
person sometimes even only by that
person on that person there's no other
person you could use that joke on and
what
what was brilliant about it is that you
want to be the underdog you want it you
want to tear someone down in a rose
petal but everyone's rooting for the
underdog and in that joke he lifted me
up and and tore me down at the same time
so he he propped me up is this bad guy
with a lot of things going for him yeah
yet made himself and yet yet tore me
apart Matt's been on Adam Devine's house
party
he's been on at midnight and he's been
on every season of roast battle comedy
central's should get me to the way
they've been forcing this dick down our
throats beautiful what was your favorite
old about you I would I would say the my
favorite one was the Oprah one because
it wasn't like it was want one it was
funny but it wasn't like negative to the
show you're on you write for The Oprah
network if in case you're wondering
where his punchlines are look under your
chairs
why why do you write for a romance drama
you look at the guy who come in - Wow on
all of my girlfriend's instagrams yeah
it wasn't like you're saying you're
talking bad about the show it was like
you you made it about me which is you
said I look like like a sleazy ass
like what do you I love it
I love it but I I mean it's my favorite
can I say this that white folks y'all
took fuck-boy international I could
compliment I mean straight up oh I don't
mean it that way I'm in the black I'm
aware of the word has been the way the
term has come back it's like a lot of
women yeah black girls do I've never
boys like I'm a boy like
will sleep with you in the moment are
you back yeah it's like boy that's
they're probably gonna be a fight like
I've never heard of yeah yeah you know
where's yes it's the it's the it's the
n-word between I think it's really
disrespectful but I haven't had a
positive boy experience yeah it's
been pretty negative what's I forgot
listen Ian Edwards everything you came
here but ensberg like if a white person
calls you the n-word and then a black
person calls you a boy that was a
good one it's a good - good was a good
pun I left out open mike tyson i hated
the I hated the the get out joke
drawn I'm really happy
you're here I'm glad to see the get out
surgery went well cuz it was it was
technically inaccurate my person is the
one who gets surgery so I get my head
I'm like that's true yeah they both get
the surgery and the surgery would be I
was seeing this for why person right in
your body is that we know it was smaller
alert but yeah
both people get the certain that the
white person's body gets thrown away
well good job
[Laughter]
[Applause]